[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you are anything like me
you miss liz wheeler i do i have missed
my friend liz wheeler lo these many
months
and you know i actually got to see her i
don't know not that long ago
you probably have not seen her in quite
a while
where has she gone was she abducted by
the ufos that were told are
soaring through our skies we have the
answers right now
liz wheeler joining the show liz thank
you for being here
michael thank you so much it wasn't the
ufos actually
it was a combined effort from the woke
cia and the russian
intelligence service that got me i want
to get into them i want to get into them
a little bit later because you i guess
you
have some serious insight here and i'm
really scared having watched those
recent commercials
but you were you were hosting a tv show
the bell of the ball the talk of the
town you were everywhere in public
anywhere i would go i would see you and
then you disappeared
what happened well as you know i was
hosting a tv show
and i then had a baby
it's actually so our babies by the way i
believe were born two days apart right
that's right two days apart our babies
were born they're now betrothed i think
a little arranged marriage between our
children see yeah this is the difference
so i stopped to have a baby
gave birth my body is amazing um this
my new show which i think we're going to
talk about has been in the works the
whole time so behind the scenes
during pregnancy i took a brief
eight-hour break during labor and
delivery to stop planning the new show
but it's been in the works since for
over a year now it's been in the works
really really excited to get it going
liz can i
confirm this phrase my body is amazing
is that the tagline of the show the liz
wheeler show
my body is amazing because that was
going to be my tag
yeah i don't know i mean that's but it
that it actually is amazing
you it is hosting the show you were
quite pregnant while you were hosting
the tv show
eventually you know it's time to get
ready have the kid
spend a little bit of time with your kid
you know and now you're you're moving
into this great new venture
i have long thought that you should
go digital i've long thought that you
you know you would be just great manning
a podcast you're terrific on research
you're terrific on opinion and
if i if i repeat your line if i say your
body's amazing then i'm going to get in
trouble with my wife so i'm going to
leave that aside for the moment
but seriously this has been a long time
in the making
and the show is just out yes yes this is
what i've wanted to do
for a really long time and it's sort of
the natural next step right
it's an actual next step because the
conservative movement as a whole
is craving bold leadership you know the
last the last four
five six years have shown us that and
it's not just bold leadership
in politics they crave bold leadership
in their thought leaders
in their news in their media in their
opinion in their research
they want somebody who isn't going to
back down to corporate wokism or
cultural marxism or teachers unions or
aoc
or big tech or leftists in congress or
mask mandates
what have you and that's what we're
going to do on the liz wheeler show
right
it's a more personal connection than
i've ever had before with my audience
which is great
i've been wanting to do that for a
really long time it's a more personal
connection
we are going to provide my sort of
trademark research
deep dive into all these topics uh make
sure that the facts are in order
and then draw conclusions from the facts
meaning offer my opinion on what we
should do
based on the reality that's the other
part of my show that i think is really
important and different
than anybody else's we're sort of in
this era that we're beyond the question
of
is this true and is this false we're
beyond um an
argument about whether someone's lying
or whether someone's being honest we are
now in a point where we're defending
reality where we have to be champions of
reality because what the left is
offering us
isn't just lies it isn't just ignorance
it's outright delusion
so on the liz wheeler show we're going
to do it all it's a more personal
connection we're going to provide the
research we're going to
hold politicians accountable we are
going to play offense
in this culture war because politics is
downstream of culture if we lose the
culture
don't even bother playing politics right
and it
i mean it's going to be great i'm so
excited so this point you've hit on
is very important the the reality issue
because yes uh obviously
two different sides in a body politic
that can have different visions of where
to go
and and and to some degree people are
always going to be interpreting the
world in
perhaps slightly different ways they're
going to see things from a different
angle
but what we're seeing now from the
modern left is a little more than that
it's not just well you see it this way
and i see it that way
it is you see it this way and i deny
objective truth and you see it this way
and i think that
actually reality can just be constructed
by whatever words that i use
or fantasies that i have and i don't
think i'm straw manning the argument
here
i think that is the explicit claim of
many of the leftist ideologies that
developed in the 20th century
so how are we supposed to fight that if
we fight that with facts and logic
they're going to say
who cares about your facts and logic
well it's actually worse than that it's
not just a matter of
this is objective truth which is reality
and the left
wants to deny that reality they then
want to force you to abandon reality and
force you to echo their delusion
so we're even a step further than just
okay you want to pretend you're santa
claus like go for it you can deny
reality no one cares
what you're doing it's when they try to
impose that on us but
what i mean conservatives in general
have a good fighting spirit right we're
happy warriors
however we are conservatives the name
conservative implies that we are trying
to conserve something that we are
playing defense and i think that that
in general has been a tactical error
against this
against this adversary and this
adversary being the radical left we've
played defense for so long so since the
1960s
you know we've lost control of many of
the institutions that form the backbone
of our moral society right
whether it's the family whether it's
traditional marriage whether it's the
public school system whether it's
hollywood
movies books entertainment music we have
surrendered these institutions to the
left because we haven't
played offense we've tried to play
defense and we've ended up sort of
defending the one yard line
and acquiescing inch by inch until you
know we topple over into the into the
other team's
uh end zone here and we can't be playing
like that anymore we have to be actively
fighting back we have to identify
these dangerous things this ideology
that the left is trying to impose on us
through our culture through our schools
through our government and we have to
deconstruct that and reclaim our country
you know i totally agree and the fact
that we've lost the
institutions notably the universities is
really awful
what drives me crazy though with these
conservatives is
they will out of one side of their mouth
they'll say we've lost
to them radical neo-marxists they've
taken over
their poisoning our children's minds and
then out of the other side of their
mouth they'll say
and because of academic freedom we can
never kick them out of the schools
and usually say wait hold on wait what
what well these guys they're spreading
lies they're
undermining our students understanding
of reason and truth
but because of freedom of speech we can
never tell them that they shouldn't say
that
you say well guys are you serious or not
are you actually are you going to go in
there and boot out the wackos i'm
thinking of
nicole hannah jones this 1619 project
fabulous she's not a journalist she's a
fabulous whose
central thesis was was wrong it was
based on a lie
she admitted it was wrong and she
admitted it was wrong the times admitted
it was wrong
she doesn't have a phd she which is you
know
if you're going to get a tenure track
job i'm not one for credentialism but
people have phds if you get tenure track
she's denied this
and there there have actually been some
squishes on the right
coming to her defense and saying this
woman should have been at unc
with fighters like that you know who
needs leftists
well right i mean that's that's part of
what we're going to do on the show is i
mean
not only do we not have room for
squishes and radical leftists
and cultural marxists we don't have room
for squish republicans either you know
if you don't have that fire in your
belly to
not just stand and defend verbally what
you believe but actually
identify the threats to our cultural
institutions and say
okay if you're going to violate our
freedom we're going to vote you out if
you're going to
stifle a student's free speech we're
going to you know levy a campaign to
make sure you're not the president of
the university anymore
if you're not ready to go on offense
then you know it's fine
some people just don't have that in them
i'm not trying to say that everyone has
to be on the
be a culture warrior on the forefront of
each one of these battlefronts but if
you don't
just have the humility to admit that and
step aside and let those of us who do
have that fire in our belly
fight this fight because i mean michael
this is what you and i do
yeah i certainly think so i mean you
know look i
i want to say in all humility for anyone
who's in politics
or media that it's not the same thing as
going out and taking bullets you know
it's not the same thing as going out
fighting literal wars
however i just watched what you alluded
to at the beginning i just watched an ad
from the cia see i was this woman she
says
i'm a intersectional latina
proud feminist woman i said what the
hell
this is what james bond became and then
i saw there was an ad for the army
and the army ad it was this woman who
says you know i was raised
at the pride parades of my lesbian
mothers and that's how i'm going to
fight the wars and i think what
you know putin are you just are you
listening are you just going to invade
now are you going to
come right across the bering strait or
something and then actually it was
juxtaposed
with an ad from the russian army and it
was these macho men like doll
they're all holding guns and firing and
i think uh do they know
what the purpose of a of a military is
well i'm i'm pretty sure that putin's
not laughing at that ca ad i'm pretty
sure putin
wrote that yeah because if i were our
adversaries i mean if i were putin i
would give his whole intelligence
community the day off because
they're not going to need to come
they're not going to need to come fully
prepared to defeat that kind of cia
well you know i i was wondering with the
i mean you're you're probably right it's
all
it's all a big op from you know the
kremlin or something or china
but assuming that
look we can laugh at these ads these ads
are really terrible and it's
yeah this makes you feel sort of ashamed
that this is where we're putting our
priorities in our resources here
in promoting our tax money and our
tanner tax dollars
but you know some of the brass in the
military
some of the top dogs and the cia
they approved this stuff they think that
this is going to serve america's
national security interests
they might have perverse views of it but
what is
what is the thought process here i mean
what what on earth would possess
our our military to to put out this
image to the world
well i think we've heard that if you
listen very closely to what these
radical leftists that joe biden has
surrounded himself with
are saying they don't define words with
reality anymore they define
words with delusion so you and i think
national security interests and we think
okay well we want to make sure that our
life liberty and our ability to pursue
happiness is secured we want to make
sure that
physically we're safe we want to make
sure our adversaries are at bay et
cetera et cetera
no they they look at our country and
they say
racism is a public health crisis yeah so
okay okay racism is a public health
crisis so first of all
it's it can be argued and i would argue
that racism is not is not institutional
we actually don't have systemic racism
in our nation anymore
we have advanced beyond that we have
fought that we have defeated it
sure there's instances of individual
racism which should always be condemned
institutionally there is there is
institutional racism in the form of
affirmative action right that's a that's
a a law in this country through
institutions it says
yeah that asian and white students are
at a disadvantage and black and hispanic
students are at an advantage
that's not what they're talking about
though no that's not what they're
talking about that's not what they're
talking about
although that is true when it comes to
asian american students trying to get
into
uh the ivy league schools especially
your alma mater i believe
yeah um but i know i mean it's it's
completely nuts when they redefine these
things so now we're talking about a
public health uni
uh emergency and they're saying racism
is a public health emergency or climate
change is a national security threat i
mean they are
trying to erase reality and replace it
with
their delusion delusion and we again we
can't just say oh you're nutty and laugh
at them we should because
they're eminently ridiculous of course
we should laugh at them but we should
also
identify well who exactly is approving
this is this something that's coming
from the white house is this something
that's coming from
a certain you know administrative agency
is this something that's approved on
what level of the military or where in
the cia
we should identify where this is coming
so that the people the american people
this isn't even a split along party
lines
this is not a republican versus a
democrat issue this is a thinking person
versus a nutty person viewpoint most of
our country
uh think that this woke crap excuse my
french is garbage
most people it doesn't matter if you're
a democrat they still think that there
are only two genders they still think
that the cia and the military should be
fighting forces
not cisgender intersectional feminists
black lives matter t-shirt wearing
you know nut jobs right so i mean it's a
matter of saying okay this is reality
please join us on the side and
let's make sure that those who are
perpetuating delusion don't have the
power to do so anymore
but why is it i agree with all that why
is it
that the institutions you know not just
some blue haired lunatic on some
you know middle tier college campus but
the actual
corporations the bureaucracy the
administrative government you whatever
why are they adopting what what is the
interest of coca-cola or delta
in adopting the crazy woke ideology of
some
stoner freshman at wesleyan
well delta i think it's obvious right
weren't they getting tax breaks
and weren't their tax breaks weren't
they getting special treatment via crony
capitalism
and wasn't that threatened given the
current administration i mean it it
sometimes those who run these
corporations are just individually woke
right sometimes their workforce is woke
and their workforce puts pressure on
them
sometimes and this i believe i would
speculate
is more often the case sometimes they
have political interests
that are benefiting their business that
are threatened if they don't count out
to what the politicians
who have control over those benefits
want right and like i said delta's a
perfect example of that they didn't want
to lose their tax breaks
so they so they decided to go woke
i don't know if that's going to help
their business or not in the case of
nike i believe it did help their
business
delta i hope it doesn't yeah i certainly
hope that they're woca cola or any of
any of the other ones
it's just so strange because the other
day
some wacko posted and said
that the american university is a
right-wing institution
and in a sense you know i think of
myself as a conservative so i want to i
i'm not in inherently opposed to
institutions
or you know obviously not to traditions
and rituals
but it just seems like all the power
centers in the country it's
you know big business how for how long
did republicans shill for big business
but they're opposed to what we want to
do the the cia
gosh how long did the republicans defend
the cia cia
seems as leftist as it gets now the fbi
seems to have been
infiltrated as well so it to what degree
are we conservatives
actually trying not to conserve what's
going on right now are we trying to
actually
change things right well this is this is
a good point and we talk about this on
episodes of my show this week we talk
about the administrative state because
donald trump famously came to washington
dc promising to drain the swamp right
that was a message that appealed across
the across the political aisle
republicans and democrats
wanted politicians who'd been in office
for too long who were slimy and
dishonest and just benefiting themselves
to be fired to be kicked out of
washington dc to no longer be in power
donald trump promised to do that and he
promised to do that in good faith and he
did his best to a certain extent
the problem is it's not something that
one person no matter if they're the
president of the united states can get
rid of
and you have to look at why you have to
travel back in history and say well
where did we get
this idea of these bloated
administrative agencies
packed with powerful bureaucrats who are
among the highest paid
bureaucrats in the entire federal
government meaning anthony fauci is paid
more than the president of the united
states he's the highest paid federal
employee out of all four million federal
employees
no joke you can look this research up
yourself we have to ask ourselves
where did this come from and the answer
is twofold first of all it came from a
congress
who allowed who legislated their own
power away from them they don't want to
take responsibility
for making rules so they pass these
vague laws
and leave it relieve the rule making
meaning defining the vagueness in the
legislation that congress passes
they leave that they defer to these
administrative agencies who then have
this power that should be
conserved just for the legislature right
so that's the first thing congress is
cowardly they don't want to take a
stance on anything and so they defer to
federal agencies
the second thing is we allowed
throughout the last hundred years
you know from woodrow wilson to lbj to
fdr we allowed
the federal government to become this
bloated apparatus we allowed supreme
court precedents
that didn't defer to administrative
agencies to now defer to administrative
agencies
and so to get rid of this in order to
actually drain the swamp
we have to undo the damage that has been
done in the last hundred years
that's not playing defense michael
that's playing offense republicans must
go
on offense and actively unravel and
unwind
so that we can recover and reclaim that
which made our
idea of limited government great i love
it you know
you brought up this great point too of
of how a lot of these issues are not
exactly republican versus democrat
left versus right there seems to be this
just this ruling class
there's like the ruling class party and
then there are the people who
are not exactly the ruling class and you
see you see it play out in the
divide between say liz cheney and
the republicans you know liz cheney
seemed
look a lot of her voting record was
fairly conservative but
really when it counted on important
political issues
she would side with the liberal ruling
class and then
even more offensively she would spend a
lot of her time
just attacking republicans and where
would she attack republicans
in the dominant ruling class newspapers
in the washington post
on the mainstream news networks cnn
wherever
uh i know obviously republicans booted
liz cheney out finally it took them long
enough
but if the republicans can't even get
their house in order
if the conservatives don't even control
the republican party the one
putatively conservative party in the
country then
what hope is there for us well that's
the thing i mean these
republicans who are establishment
republicans the ones that i would call
squishes you know whether it be
mitt romney whether it be liz cheney i
mean i i don't know if they just don't
understand that the popular kids in the
mainstream media don't actually like
them they're just using them as pawns
they don't actually want to be your
friend
they don't actually respect your
viewpoint the mainstream media and the
leftists that control the mainstream
media
just like to purport the narrative that
the republican party is fractured right
and we're always michael the republican
party is always
going to have more individual thought
than the democratic party we're nev
we're never going to walk in lockstep
the way the democrats do
because the idea of limited government
the idea of individual liberties and
freedoms
is to allow people to think differently
to allow people to live differently
we i mean it's essentially the party of
independent thought so you're going to
have free thinkers who are courageous
enough
to contradict you know the people that
are leading the party that's always
going to happen
it's not even necessarily a bad thing in
and of itself you just have to be ready
to say nope you're wrong this is what
the party's going to do but you can't
allow the mainstream media to report
this narrative that we are a fractured
party
that we're going you know that we're
going to break apart that we don't know
what we stand for like
no the mainstream media wants you to
think that and they're using these
squish republicans
to to paint a false picture no that
that's a great point and you you know
you
you are quite insightful on a great many
topics but especially with the media
you've got a really keen view and it's
true i mean as much as i want to boot
the
liz cheney types out of gop leadership
it is the case that the the media has an
interest here in splitting up the
republican party so that we don't win in
2022 or
2024 or or whenever now
i've got to get to a topic that look you
know this is important
the parties and the elections the power
and whatever
the ufos liz i want to know you
disappeared at a very convenient time
now you've just reappeared you know all
of a sudden when all these little
saucers and tic tacs and things are
flying around
what do you know you can't see my
spaceship in this frame right
i can check i can i can see sort of
little green antennae coming up there
no i pinned that with a hair clip i
pinned it to my ifv
what do i think of it in all seriousness
i told you is it is it just an op is
this like a fake thing
i've been texting all my friends in the
dod i've been texting all my friends in
the national security community
what do you know tell me your secrets um
and disappointingly to their credit
they've not released much classified
information to me much
my speculation this is purely
speculation because who's not interested
in this right you see those videos and
you're like
whoa they're coming for us my
speculation is that it's
probably not aliens it's probably not
my speculation is that it's either
military surveillance
that we're not being told about because
you know i mean there are times that
even
training operations you know you turn on
you turn on your stealth
type of settings and you show up
differently on radar screens that
happens
there's also sometimes not physical
objects that are used for surveillance
like some of these things it wouldn't
surprise me if it's more like hologram
type technology
that's what i actually think a lot of it
is because that would allow it to move
you know beyond the scope of our of our
technology right to defy gravity to not
have acceleration and breaking periods
to be able to go up and down and side to
side
that kind of stuff um almost like
projections or holograms i haven't heard
a lot of people talking about that
but i'd be interested in the expert's
advice on that let's
and you know as outlandish as that might
sound if the alternative is little
little green men coming from venus you
know then
that's right that's right i know i i
agree and there is also
you always have wait do you think it's
aliens i don't i'm very ant
this is my least popular opinion i don't
think
that there is any reason to believe that
any life exists whatsoever
outside of the earth i'm not saying it
doesn't i'm not saying definitively
it does but i just you always hear
people one everyone wants there to be
aliens because it's kind of fun and
interesting
but two you'll always hear people say
well that michael the universe is so
big so it's just a matter of probability
that there's life on other planets and i
think well
you know to ascertain a probability you
need to know
literally anything about the subject but
about the subject of how
life is we don't we don't we just don't
know anything we have no idea about
the scientific origins of life so you
know
until we know something about that i i
can't venture a probability of
if there's life on pluto or something no
i mean as catholics it's compatible with
catholic theology you know with god all
things are possible
he created us he could create other life
sure but i agree that there's a
difference between
could be possible certainly versus
have evidence that it is yeah as
evidence that it is and to my knowledge
there is no evidence right it's just
people's speculation
no and the tic tacs and the little you
know tic tacs that someday we'll find
out is xi
i'm just like maybe maybe your oxygen
mask was on a little loose that day
yeah that's true i know we'll see
although all this denial
sure sounds like something an alien
would say
oh well we'll leave that for the
audience to decide
liz it is a little bit like an alien
right when you grow another human in
your body
that is and i don't know i mean i
thankfully you know
my wife had a very tough time of it she
had a c-section and uh but
that all the more so even the natural
birth is sort of like that
you know reaching out in the kind of
like in the movies and everything i
don't know thankfully i was behind the
screen
so i didn't have to see it i am i am
genuinely
very very excited about your show i have
i'm not flattering i'm not
you know just saying this you know out
of nowhere
i have missed you in the public
discourse and i'm glad you're back
and i know the show is going to be a
smash it is the liz wheeler show where
can people find it
thank you so much michael i appreciate
that and you do actually have to say
that because you know that i'll text you
to ask you
obsessively about the episodes if you
don't that's right
lizwheelershow.com uh please subscribe
please give me five star reviews uh
please actually write a review because
in order to climb up the charts and beat
michael on itunes
we need those five star ratings we need
those reviews we need those
subscriptions
and we're having a ton of fun so go to
lizwheelershow.com and if they let's say
someone just you know
they don't do urls what is this the 90s
people go have a browser
so they're on they can get it just on
apple podcast just search liz wielder
show
yeah definitely and that's what
lizwheelershow.com takes you to all the
different podcast platforms but you can
go to anywhere that you get
anywhere that you listen to podcasts we
will be there it's on rumble it's on
youtube
right rumble these are like they're all
these new things i don't know it's on
myspace it's on livejournal it's on
zanga it's on instant messenger it's on
a lot of places liz
i before we go by the way everybody go
subscribe go check out the show leave a
five-star review
and uh and then if it turns out that liz
is an alien we're gonna we'll have to
recalibrate
okay we'll have to but we're you're
gonna be talking about lots of aliens
aliens from outer space you'll be
talking about aliens from guatemala and
nicaragua
and the issues at the southern border
you'll be talking about all all manner
of public policy issues on the show
everything everything's wheeler show liz
so good to be with you
see you soon thank you michael
[Music]
[Music]
you